foreign
Jenny joins us up next in NYC Jenny
welcome to the show
hi guys thank
you absolutely how can John and I help
okay so we owe a hundred and seventeen
thousand dollars
and get mostly Consumer Debt 20 000 of
those are to the IRS we are already on
payment funds with the IRS that's the
first thing we did when we found out
with Rio the money
we've made every stupid financial
decision possible with NATO
and um welcome to the club
I am expecting a child in two months I
am currently working remotely I have one
child in school and one with me while I
work remotely and we can choose money
I thought we were leaving within our
means
we thought we were doing everything we
had to do until I noticed that all of
our credit cards were maxing out and I'm
like how is this possible no we can't do
that I did a detailed budget and we had
a 1100 deficit on a monthly basis
and we've been doing that for the past
almost year
that's how you go into 117 000 in debt
for sure yes and not only that we
purchased a home we bought the least
expensive home that we can purchase in
the New York City area New Jersey area
and
um once you open one wall that you think
oh five thousand numbers that I have
been saved up will help us do this one
wall once you open that one wall you
realize that you just
um it was a money pit and we've spent
over a hundred thousand dollars fixing
so that's where most of our Consumer
Debt comes from it's us putting stuff on
the credit cards to fix the house
because once one thing was fixed 20
other things were broken and then we
have car ratios we don't have any car
payments our cards really old and has
been paid for but like I said everything
else it's um a lot of Consumer Debt now
coin we fill it out and I've been
listening to you guys for the past three
weeks since we started our budget I'm
I'm angry I'm mad I don't know what else
to do and I am every feeling in between
to get me started and motivated to just
do it my husband has been able to pick
up
12 extra hours in overtime at work but
just to commute to work it cost us
around twelve hundred dollars a month
between tolls and gas we are about two
hours away from where we live and taking
public transportation is going to be a
six hour commute three dollar and three
coming back what's he doing for work
um he works at an airport and in another
state
hmm so he is um he helped with the audit
of
um the documents that are needed for
that
hey Jenny I'm going to ask you a hard
question okay and I'm I normally make
jokes about this and I'm not playing
okay I'm being I hear it in your voice
okay you're a scared
um mother of young kids with another one
on the way okay I hear it in you
um
there is something and people can roll
their eyes and I get that and it's worth
rolling your eyes at but if you if
you're born and raised in Texas and
you're born and raised in New York
there's an extra you can't leave
right
are you connected to New York
yes and well we have our employment who
are very flexible with us one that's one
of them second one is that we actually
moved to the next date closer just
because we couldn't afford living in New
York anymore no I I'm talking about cut
ties completely and go to another state
where you can keep your income your
state income tax where you can get some
uh some breath in your life you've
created a life for yourself that your
bodies cannot exist in
you cannot commute six hours a day and
be parents and be married and be
connected to one another you just can't
you can't have this you can't have run a
deficit of eleven hundred dollars twelve
hundred of that is just in taxes and in
tolls and in gas commuting
like you've created a life that you
can't exist in and it may be that the
Northeast isn't the place for you and
your family right now
is that an option for you
cut ties with this house You've Lost
Your you've lost it it's fine can we go
somewhere and start over because this
isn't working man you're drowning
it is we are so
um we are drowning and we made it to the
point where we are now at a 700 per
place with the overtime that we're going
to be doing I know but that's I know hun
but that's temporary
yeah you're working overtime you're
commuting all over the place your your
cars are falling apart right you see
there's so much these are Band-Aids
am I right if I'm wrong tell me but it
sounds like I'm right you're right
the extra 700 throwing at 117 000 it is
a never-ending battle at that point and
so we're trying to find any way you can
drastically reduce expenses and increase
or keep your income and that might mean
making some big sacrifices that you
don't want to do right now
yeah what's your mortgage payment
uh 2400 what's your take-home pay
clean after everything it's 6200.
if you
are you is a house in sellable condition
could you sell it and not lose your
backside I won't be able to lose after
everything we've invested in the house
was we'll do
y'all would do okay
no we would not oh you would
it would be a loss yes could you sell it
um take out what you've invested in it
versus what you owe could you get out
clean
what's it worth and what's left on the
mortgage
um we gave a 20 down the houses was
what we purchased it at right now 465.
um and what's your mortgage
so we give 20 down so whatever that was
90 something thousand dollars okay
that's all that has been paid in the
house we've invested over a hundred and
twenty thousand dollars in payment and
you're getting your 20 back but you're
still in the hole because of all the six
figures you invested into it
yeah that's called sunk cost fallacy you
may never get that money back yes so
that may be the biggest stupid tax you
pay in your life but the problem I'm
seeing right now is that forty percent
of your take-home pay is going towards
the mortgage
yes and that's before the tolls and the
gas and the kids and so right now you
can't breathe
so this isn't a sustainable lifestyle to
begin with even with the extra 700
coming in
okay so I I
this is really hard because it's one of
those things that we're like severely
we're afraid of the unknown I don't
think we'll be able to make what we make
now in another state
and we'll still have a hundred and
seventeen thousand dollars in debt in
another state
who and we won't be able to bring home
what we're bringing now
I wouldn't put that out into the world
um you you work remote correct could you
move out of New York
um they're doing me a favor because I am
a high risk pregnancy
but now I'm required in the office what
do you make annually
I make seventy thousand dollars doing
what
I'm an HR analyst you absolutely can
make seventy thousand dollars outside of
New York
and if you make sixty thousand dollars
in the state of Tennessee you keep a
chunk of that money because there's no
state income tax
and you can make sixty thousand dollars
wow being a math teacher in the right
School District so here's what I'm
saying I don't want you to limit
yourself on Fantasy on imagination
because y'all are in desperate need of
data of facts and your husband what does
he do at the airport
two years of coordinator that helped
with air aircraft records okay I travel
all over the country so does George
we've been to a lot of airports they
need a lot of coordination across across
the country okay and I bet he could
coordinate all kinds of different things
here's what I'm saying
you'll have to get real about the fact
that you'll have created a life for
yourselves that is not sustainable you
cannot live in the Life you've created
whether that means move whether that
means different jobs whether it means
sell your house and yes you're going to
eat the hundred thousand dollars you put
into it that stinks but you can get out
even Steven rent for a couple of years
move to Kansas move to Texas I don't
care what you do
but I want you to imagine a life where
you've got peace and you got to build
from there